alle meine Freunde Bekannten nennen mich
ganz einfach Fürst Norbert ich kann mich
mit einem Dokument so nicht
identifizieren wo eine Glaubhaftmachung
einer Staatsangehörigkeit drauf ist die
von Adolf Hitler eingeführt worden ist
das ist der erste Punkt ich bin der
oberste souverän des Staates Königreich
Deutschland und die zweite Sache ist
dieses andere Symbol das ist das Symbol
von Satan das ist deutlich zu erkennen
wer und was aber verbirgt sich hinter
diesen reichsbürgern und welches Risiko
sind sie für unsere Gesellschaft das
schauen wir uns in dieser Kontext Folge
etwas näher an herzlich willkommen
bevor wir klären ob reichsbürgerinnen
und Reichsbürger für Deutschland
gefährlich werden könnten zunächst mal
was ist das überhaupt denn Reichsbürger
das Wort ist ein Sammelbegriff für eine
Bewegung die vor allem eines eint die
fundamentale Ablehnung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und ihres
Rechtssystems Reichsbürger sind ja
Überzeugung dass die Bundesrepublik nur
ein Lügenkonstrukt ist und dass wir in
Wahrheit noch im Deutschen Reich Leben
fakt ist natürlich die Zeit des
Deutschen Reiches endete 1945 als
Deutschland im Zweiten Weltkrieg besiegt
wurde viele Anhängerinnen und Anhänger
der Szene aber sind der Ansicht des
Deutschland keine gültige Verfassung
habe manche glauben sogar Deutschland
wäre eine GmbH zudem glauben einige des
Deutschlands sich immer noch im Krieg
befindet und die Alliierten im Geheimen
Besatzer Deutschland sind seitdem
Deutschland am 8 mai kapituliert hat war
das Land nie wieder souverän sondern
eine Verwaltung der Alliierten in dem
sogenannten vereinigten
Wirtschaftsgebiet der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland mit anderen Worten ein
handelskonstrukt wahr ist spätestens
seit dem 2+4 Vertrag von 1990 wurde die
endgültige Souveränität des vereinten
Deutschlands hergestellt was die
Anhänger und Anhängerinnen des
reichsgedankens so schwer greifbar macht
sie sind nicht einheitlich organisiert
und sie haben auch keine eindeutigen
gemeinsamen Ziel wie gefährlich die
Szene aber ist möchte ich anhand von
drei Punkten beleuchten beginnen wir mit
ihrem Gedankengut die Thesen der
reichsbürgerbewegung bestehen aus
verschwörungsmythen die Gefahr daran ist
dass Menschen die sich in dieser Welt
verirrt haben häufig nicht mehr von der
Wahrheit zu erreichen sind es gibt
Studien die zeigen dass Menschen mit
einem bestimmten
persönlichkeitsschema besonders anfällig
sind und wir wissen wenn wirtschaftlich
politisch unruhige Zeiten dann ist der
Glaube an Verschwörungstheorien
ausgeprägt und Menschen die nach einer
Handlungsanweisung suchen finden diese
in einer rechtsextremen und oder
antisemitischen
verschwörungsvorstellungen im Milieu von
reichsbürgern selbstverwaltern und
souveränisten dass ich beobachte ist es
so dass die Ideologie
grundsätzlich rechtsextreme Elemente
beinhaltet und antisemitische und die
antisemitischen überwiegender deutlich
da sind es dann die gierigen Banker oder
das Finanzkapital die Wall Street oder
die Ostküste was alles dann Codes immer
sind für eigentlich das Judentum und
sowohl das
verschwörungsideologische Weltbild als
auch der Antisemitismus machen die
Bewegung anschlussfähig an andere
Milieus das Gefährliche an all diesen
Ideologien ist laut Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz dass sich ideologische
Überschneidungen zur
rechtsextremistischen Szene finden und
das ist das was ich meine nicht alle
Menschen die dort sind sind
rechtsextreme genau aber das was sie
verstanden haben
in eine Verschwörungstheorie ein die
grundsätzlich strukturell rechtsextreme
und strukturell antisemitisch ist von
23.000 Personen die zur Szene der
Reichsbürger gehören werden auf jeden
Fall etwa
1.250 der rechtsextremen Szene
zugerechnet und damit sind wir bei
Gefahren Punkt Nummer zwei die
Demokratie Feindlichkeit und damit ein
Weltbild in dem aus Staatsverdrossenheit
schnell Staats Hass werden kann die
harmloseste Ausprägung ist dabei noch
das Reichsbürger und reichsbürgerinnen
sich häufig weigern Steuern und Gebühren
zu zahlen man kriegt regelmäßig
Erklärungen die sich Seiten umfassen
teilweise 50 60 Seiten wo dezidiert
begründet wird warum das Grundgesetz
nicht existiert warum die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland nicht existiert und und die
Fälle landen häufig vor Gericht und
kosten natürlich erhebliche Steuergelder
noch aggressiver aber ist dann häufig
das Auftreten von reichsbürgern und
reichsbürgerinnen gegenüber Polizisten
gerichtsvollzieherinnen sowie anderen
Hamster
Amtsträger geschrieben
pseudo Haftbefehle erstellt und
Strafzahlungen gefordert eingefordert
das alles soll der Einschüchterung
dienen und die Krise der corona-pandemie
hat offensichtlich zu einer weiteren
Radikalisierung der Szene beigetragen
einige Menschen sind empfänglich
geworden für vermeintliche
Freiheitskämpfe und es zeigt sich dass
sie zunehmend bereit sind ihre
Vorstellungen auch gewaltsam
durchzusetzen und damit sind wir bei
Punkt Nummer 3 die Gewaltbereitschaft
des Szene sie wurde 2012 deutlich als
sich Reichsbürger in Sachsen als
Polizisten verkleideten und einen
Gerichtsvollzieher kurzzeitig Festnahmen
und verletzt 2016 dann der Täter von
Georgensgmünd war schwer bewaffnet er
trug eine kugelsichere Weste nach dem
tödlichen Angriff gegen Polizisten gilt
die bundesweite Beobachtung der
reichsbürgerbewegung durch den
Verfassungsschutz als sicher seit
November 2016 beobachten die
Sicherheitsbehörden die
reichsbürgerbewegung intensiver durch
die Vorfälle wurde nochmals deutlich
dass das Potenzial zur
Gewaltbereitschaft sehr hoch ist diese
Einschätzung bestätigte sich endgültig
im vergangenen Jahr er soll der Kopf
einer terroristischen Vereinigung sein
die laut Bundesanwaltschaft einen
regierungsumsturz in Deutschland plante
ein adliger aus Frankfurt der der
reichsbürgerszene zugeordnet wird es ist
eine von 25 Festnahmen die heute früh in
ganz Deutschland stattfanden über 3000
spezialkräfte der Polizei und des BKA
durchsuchten 130 Objekte in mehreren
Bundesländern die Terrorvereinigung soll
seit über einem Jahr Pläne für einen
Sturz der Regierung geschmiedet haben es
gab feindeslisten mit Namen hochrangiger
Politiker Waffen und tausende
schussmunition der Verdacht die
sogenannten Reichsbürger hatten Pläne
für einen Umsturz einige der
Verdächtigen wollten dabei offenbar in
das Reichstagsgebäude eindringen um dort
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung und
Abgeordnete festzulegen
zu den Verhafteten Personen gehörten
neben einem Bundeswehrsoldaten auch
mehrere Reservisten sowie die ehemalige
afd-abgeordnete Birgit malsack winkemann
man muss diese Umtriebe dieser wohl
terroristischen Vereinigungen schon sehr
ernst nehmen denn nach allem was wir in
letzter Zeit hier schon durch
Überwachungsmaßnahmen auch feststellen
mussten war es die feste Absicht dieser
Gruppierung auch wenn das vielleicht ein
untauglicher Versuch war aber jedenfalls
wirklich unsere Staatsordnung völlig zu
beseitigen und das waren nur einige
Beispiele für Gewalttaten der
reichsbürgerbewegung insgesamt gelten
aktuell
2100 Personen aus der Szene als Gewalt
orientiert immer wieder werden innerhalb
des Milieus Waffen und Munition durch
die Polizei sichergestellt was lässt
sich also festhalten das ist ja eine
Gefahr die in diesem Land ganz real und
das haben auch die bisherigen
Erkenntnisse gezeigt die Gruppierung ist
mit rund
23.000 Anhängern wahrlich nicht zu
vernachlässigen noch immer verfügen etwa
500 Personen aus diesem Spektrum über
eine waffenlizenz und die Razzia im
vergangenen Dezember hat deutlich
gemacht es nicht nur gesellschaftliche
Randfiguren zur Szene gehören sondern da
finden sich unter anderem ehemalige und
aktive Angehörige der Polizei und auch
ehemalige Bundeswehrsoldaten tatsächlich
ist auch noch mal zu bedenken dass ihr
Sicherheitskräfte auch involviert
gewesen sind das ist wirklich eine sehr
spezielle und sehr gefährliche Allianz
nach der großrazieher diskutierte die
Regierung darüber welche Maßnahmen zur
Terrorabwehr getroffen werden sollen ich
finde immer wenn halbautomatische
Kriegswaffen gehören nicht in die Hände
von Menschen
insofern ist es glaube ich ein wichtiger
und richtiger Punkt darüber zu
verhandeln der Regierungspartner FDP ist
aber gegen eine Verschärfung des
Waffenrechts worin sich die Ampel einig
ist verfassungsfeindliche Beamte sollen
in Zukunft einfacher aus dem
öffentlichen Dienst entfernt werden
können sicherlich ein guter Ansatz doch
gleichzeitig bleibt es große Problem
besteht Gesellschaft und Politik haben
noch keine geeignete Antwort auf diese
Art von
verschwörungserzählungen gefunden
zumindest werden sie nicht mehr als
reine Spinner unterschätzt was denken
sie über die reichsbürgerbewegung
schreiben Sie es mir gerne in die
Kommentare und abonnieren Sie auch gerne
unseren Kanal wenn Sie mehr von Kontext
sehen wollen dann schauen Sie doch gerne
diese Folge an bei der wir die
steigenden Energiepreise in den Kontext
gesetzt haben und wenn Sie noch mehr
über die reichsbürgerbewegung wissen
wollen dann empfehle ich Ihnen dieses
Video